okay well Harry kroto
Florida State University and I got some
questions here and the first one is for
a jump jam cami of University of Western
Ontario as you say science is about
asking questions in your experience what
are the most important questions
scientists I should ask themselves and
what are the big questions they should
be working on well I'm the last person
to us that because I don't know I don't
don't look at any questions other than
the ones that interests me
I've been very fortunate that being
found everything fascinating and say I'm
in a lecture and I see a light on the on
the ceiling reflection from someone's
watch I have to find out whose watch it
is it's just a puzzle and for me life is
a puzzle whenever I'm anywhere something
that I don't understand I have to find
out how it works
as far as science is concerned I don't
think about the big questions at all I
just think about the things that
interests me and even if they're not
very exciting or don't appear very
exciting but interest me I followed them
through and in fact the discovery of c60
was such a problem it wasn't the most
exciting problem I could think of it was
interesting for me but it turned up this
big surprise and so the lesson that I've
learned all through my life is that just
look at things that interest you and
just sometimes they may may turn out to
be incredibly fascinating